BENE
rimango con la pace
Esco da tam
per spiegarlo
Laggiù
Questo
più della tua aria c'è un problema oggi lo farò
miami
i due con la notte dove
prometto
Quello
il trotto
poi in Canada
Vado alla mia vista della città a griglia
quando compagnia
andare
e te lo dirò
no no
per me
vado a prendere
tra 12 ore
Oggi
no no
noi uomini
ho provato io stesso
efe
e lo farai
non dover mai crollare
il mio ragazzo
e che ha ristagnato e che dice in tono di
ai
Per il Perù abbraccio solo con Emma e
personale
i miei raccolti
sonno
la vita non è facile
Sono appena passato a trovarti
di notte
perché no no
non c'è futuro
e non è un eterno mio eterno ti ama